this is a production of Cornell
University seriously at with USDA my
focus is mostly on plant biology and
looking at my physiology today what I
want to try and do is to give you some
sense of what the public health
consequences are and we consider this as
a good so before I do that however I
want to introduce you to sort of the
basic concepts I'm sure a lot of this is
review for new humanity produces carbon
dioxide any source of carbon whether
that source of carbon is coal or
gasoline whatever oxygen you burn it
carbon oxygen carbon dioxide so about 90
percent of that comes from fossil fuels
and cement about 10 percent from
deforestation about 50 percent stays in
the atmosphere a quarter of it goes back
into the land through photosynthesis and
about a quarter of it is making the
oceans and water sources more acidic
you've seen the Keeling curve before I'm
sure but this is historically the the
highest co2 we've seen last million
years or so and it's really
unprecedented and how quickly it's
rising to be logical terms if you look
at the different projections of where it
will go
depends on the model you have the Green
Line here which I refer to as the
everyone hold hand to drive a Prius line
and then you have this dashed line which
is the business-as-usual line and that's
pretty much where we're headed at the
moment so there's been very little
effort even with the Paris Accords and
so forth and actually removing or
lowering our carbon emissions so the
question I often get asked is well ok
who gives a flying Fig whether or not
carbon dioxide is 300 or 400 or 500 or
800 parts per million what differences
well the major difference is an indirect
effect due to warmer temperatures if you
look at the overall composition of the
air you see all the major gases but then
you see two that are very important even
though they're in small quantities and
those are considered to be global
warming gases and then some of what does
that mean what does it mean if I have a
global word in gas what what's special
about them and the special thing about
them is that they're musical let me
explain that well before I do any
anybody here that plays that stringed
instrument any musicians in the group
excellent thank you so my question is
for you
let's say that I tuned two strings to
the same key okay they're both next to
each other and they're tuned to the same
frequency and I get one key or one
string what what the string that's to do
it'll vibrate right it'll resonate but
if I'm a Republican it's a basic
physical concept and that resonance
absorbs energy that the other string is
going out well it turns out this is also
true for molecules and these particular
molecules carbon dioxide and water vapor
the molecular bonds are such that they
resonate they don't keep resonating the
key of a like a guitar string but they
resonate in the key of them Freret so
whenever they come into contact with
heat they resonate they would absorb
some heat that would otherwise be lost
and that is part of the natural
greenhouse effect without water vapor
and without carbon dioxide the average
surface temperature would be about minus
18 degrees Celsius you'd all be sitting
around the farm you know and a fire and
you know shivering so this natural
greenhouse effect is one of the reasons
why life is in fact possible
but one little variation on this is that
remember its co2 and water vapor and
you'll notice that the temperature
increase on the globe is not uniform you
say global warming of one degree but
that's an average it's not rising the
same way everywhere why what what's
going on
well you have two different greenhouse
gases so where on earth is the air warm
and moist and water vapors the dominant
greenhouse gas tropics absolutely so the
rise in carbon dioxide is cause that to
be a great but it's not gonna have a
huge effect because water vapor is the
dominant gas now flip that around where
is the air dry doesn't hold a lot of
water vapor and therefore it's going to
have a faster rate of water it holds
absolutely see we have the second French
Connection where else is the air warm
and dry right so we expect to see
increase in desert vacation all right as
you go up in altitude there becomes
alright so greater effect in terms of
greater effect in terms of seasons with
winter temperatures warming more than
summer temperatures okay so that is sort
of a key twist to understand when we
talk about global warming or climate
change is that the surface temperature
is not changing the same way because of
these distribution of water vapor and
carbon dioxide
hopefully that's on the same page on
that now there's going to be some plant
biology consequences of this as I'm sure
you're aware less temperature increase
with water vapors high but or
precipitation greater temperature
increase with latitude or altitude
increasing densification increasing
drought so in rising sea levels from
increased polar and glacial melt
there's another reason why you should
give a flying pig plants are essential
to life what are the four things plants
need to grow I picked on you once
already what plants need to grow water
I'm not trying to trick you I heard
water ideas doing all right so waters
lie nutrients carbon dioxide is that a
fair assessment those are the four major
resources okay suppose your imagination
suppose for the sake of argument that
the amount of nitrogen in the soils all
over the world had gone up by 25 percent
in your lifetime
would that have an impact on plant
biology of course and here's the 64
million on the same way to that change
what does that mean in terms of the
ecology
what does that mean in terms about
diversification what does that mean in
terms of crop production what does that
mean in terms of evolution now you can
remove your imagination because we know
that carbon dioxide has in fact gone up
by 30 percent in my lifetime I'm older
so it's an altered plant biology well
but that's a good thing I mean I know
it's a good thing because I went to the
ExxonMobil website and I saw this slide
this is loblolly pine and if I give
loblolly pine more carbon dioxide grow
smart any foresters here and been city
forestry really know what happens when
it when a tree goat when if what happens
to do the quality of the wood for a tree
that grows very quickly
weaker oh yeah I didn't find out on the
website and there's another thing I
didn't find on the website it turns out
I know crazy stuff right it turns out
that there are plants like kudzu that
also respond to carbon dioxide so to
come out and say well it's often be
inter for the official co2 is going to
be the mankind straight savior it's
gonna be the second birth of Eden which
was actually in a Wall Street Journal
good no not going to happen are they
gonna be consequences
oh yeah it's the final little resource
for plant growth plants are beneficial
to some parts but not all parts of human
society not all plants respond the same
way and there's going to be qualitative
components of plant biology so we're on
the same page I hope in terms of
understanding the consequences of
climate and carbon dioxide at the very
plants so let's look at it now in terms
of health well let's focus for a moment
on the good malaria is considered to be
a worldwide scourge between 400 and 500
thousand children under the age of five
die every year from life particularly in
sub-saharan Africa there are many
different ways that people have used to
counter malaria curing malaria once you
have affected one of them is through
Prairie Mesa particularly what are
called armies and combination therapies
are denisa them which is a plant based
on it goes from the lab and then
different things are added to it
but it basically is used the artisan
kills the Plasmodium parasite but there
are some additional drugs that are added
to it so that it can't but could reoccur
but this is the source fergan for
Artemis nun Artemisia annua
and this is the strong peroxide bridge
that is used to kill Maria now the
question is if plants respond to co2
then what is the response of this plant
to co2 and particularly what does it do
to the concentration excuse me of
artemisinin and that's what we've tried
to find out sorry this was some of the
issue information from the previous
slide the long-acting drugs that are
avatar of artemisinin in order to make
sure that the Plasmodium doesn't recur
so what have recent changes and see what
he's done to this particular chemical
and to find out we looked at free air
co2 enrichment studies for RT Mason and
content it's a high carbon compound
there's no nitrogen went up at the CM
ratio it's a very good correlation
between c2n and carbon dioxide we use
this relationship to then go to
different air barium throughout china
and to look at RT museum that had been
collected since the early 1900s when the
co2 was about 300 and 310 parts per
million and then through to about 385
parts per million and what they found
was that they estimated artemisinin in
these concentrations pretty much
mimicked what was happening to the co2
concentration atmospheric lake and we
then test
this a field experiment where we
actually gave the planets more carbon
dioxide and produced more enemies in it
as a result of these experiments people
in China and the drug company that
produces our enemies and that is now
growing them under high co2 so they can
get more Artemisia per unit per plant
under these conditions so it's
increasing the concentration of a drug
is used the counter at malaria cool so
it's a common leave but may be an
essential pharmacological resource and
recent increases seem to be associated
with an increase in that particular drug
are there other plant-based drugs that
could be responding I don't know we
haven't looked there yet what native
medicines the native plants are being
affected 2 to 3 billion people in the
world don't go to the corner Walgreens
to get the prescription filled great
they rely on native plants as a source
of medicine how are those things
infected by carbon dioxide how are they
being affected in terms of distribution
by climate change what about the bad
well I don't know about you I suffer
from seasonal allergies and from a
seasonal allergy point of view their
main three major sources trees
springtime weeds and grasses in the
summer and radley possibly involve
driving a short-day plant it's pretty
good model to start with so we started
with this in chambers growth chambers
where we could modify the carbon dioxide
and collect the pollen from the catkins
we looked at this was done in the late
90s and we looked at 280 parts per
million pre-industrial co2 370 at the
time ambient and then 600 and we saw
this is grams for plant and dry biomass
and perhaps more to the point this is
pollen production so 5 grams for plant
at 3 industrial 11 grams for plan end of
the 20th century
620 grams for plant probably that
sometime this century
not only is graduate increasing its
pollen production but bensinger
who was a med student at the time did
some Eliza work also showing that the
concentration of ambien a one principal
allergen on the pollen was actually
going up to the concentration was
changing so by all that's kind of
interesting to me anything oh come on
it's a chamber study the chamber study
nobody cares about chambers how do you
build up on that how do you go from the
lab to the real world money this is the
face system this was done at Duke forest
and you can see the scale I'm hopefully
here a little bit these are the pipes
that are pushing carbon dioxide into the
center of this ring now we may not be
able to see it but there looks like a
little semicolon here that's actually a
railroad track they had to bring a 6-ton
tank of carbon dioxide on a daily basis
in order to provide the carbon dioxide
to fumigate these rates the bill alone
for carbon dioxide was a million dollars
a year I had two thousand dollars in
discretionary funds five minutes of time
was not going to do it for me so how do
I do this how do I go from the chamber
to the real world
hmm Mon Aloha
manalo why do you suppose they monitor
curb and outside I mean I'm sure ye gosh
you know great daiquiris but why Hawaii
what do you think any ideas
punches no influence our industry
exactly exactly
Hawaii is the most isolated geographic
isolated spot on earth and he monitored
at 10,000 feet trust me when I tell you
the carbon dioxide in this room is not
405 parts per million it's 600 or 700
parts flying all right uh uh maybe what
we can do is to look at ragweed along a
urban rural gradient for the city which
is already longer and has more carbon
dioxide wouldn't be a harbinger of
things to come and you know what it's
cheap
this is costing million dollars a year
so that's what we did we dug our sights
the Inner Harbor of Baltimore was our
urban site suburban and an organic farm
as the real site we moved our soil we
made it uniformly added monitoring and
I'm sorry as an academic I have to show
you at least one slide that nobody in
the back row can see my slide and locate
but basically carbon dioxide from rural
to suburban urban went up four-year high
temperature went up change in season
length the number of cross three days
went up we were worried about ozone but
we saw whenever we had an ozone event in
city but then to four to five hour
period the reading say knows that that
ozone event out in the and the suburbs
in the rural Sun so there was more
nitrogen deposited in the urban site but
we had our own soil which had a high
amount of nitrogen to begin with
and so the amount of nitrogen difference
was small relative to the amount of
nitrogen we had in our initial soil
initial soil was the same and had the
same seed bank we've watered it along
the transect try to maintain it as
uniform as possible so all right just
some pictures here if you look closely
you'll see Jimmy Hoffa this is our
monitor and use rotor rods to monitor
the pollen and this is our rad week on
on the farm site the suburban site and
the downtown site this is on per plant
basis where the curves are basically
averaged so being a short day plant and
start to flower here and the farm site
or control side if you will right around
this time maximized around 245 days and
they stopped these two arrows
essentially correspond to the beginning
and maximum time at the farm you can see
it's large a little bit earlier at the
suburban a lot earlier in the downtown
site and basically on average you'd look
at the area under the curve a ragweed
plant growing under high co2 or warm
more co2 and warmer temperatures is
producing about tenfold more pollen and
same class in the farm cool we went from
the chamber to an outdoor experiment all
right it's a global problem I showed
this to the folks that science in nature
and they said yeah it's a global problem
dummy now to do a global solution okay
now I'm really stuck what do I do now oh
I use that very sophisticated instrument
on my desk hello you don't know me oh
but you're an allergist right I'm a
plant physiologist from us take note on
that don't hang up on it right hello
so I told it allergists around the
country and I said can you help me I'm
looking to see if you have any long-term
data on the scarred end of the ragweed
season I want to see if it was in recent
decades there's been a climate induced
change in the season lengths of ragweed
exposure and I want to compare it to a
global model because the global model
remember based on carbon dioxide and
water vapor is that as I move northward
I'm going to see a bigger effect so if I
start in the environs of East Texas it's
warm and humid and go up to Canada I
should ostensibly see a change in the
ragweed season so I found enough folks
who are interested and this is what we
saw that going from the East Texas it's
not direct but as we went from East
Texas up into southern Canada over the
last since the 90s the season has
changed it has changed in real-time and
this got published in PNAS so alright
well that's that's better let's do the
world
so I I'd used email this time I
published a TAS oh okay so what we've
been doing now is to look at not just
Bradley but to look at all flowering
species for as many different locations
in the northern hemisphere that we could
find and the longest one we had was
actually the longest data we had was
from Turku Finland going back to the
1970s this is total seasonal pollen the
total amount of pollen from spring
through fall and looking at the Train
function that year and this is for
Finland this is for wreak havoc Iceland
Kansas City Missouri
Ava Switzerland and there's a lot of
variation in the data I won't go through
all of it but if you look at the each of
these is a separate point along from
from different locations and this is a
pretention percent change in pollen load
per year as a function of changes and T
max men over that time period
so what we're seeing is that the
temperature increase as it goes up is
also driving the overall pollen load per
year for both the maximum and the
minimum temperatures so we're seeing in
real time with temperatures a change and
the cumulative amount of pollen that
you're being exposed to okay so the bad
changes and policies and changes in
pollen amounts changes and Colin
allergenicity okay let's go to the oMG
part let's take a minute all right
turns out that fire frequency and be
associated with potassium levels and
plant material less potassium the more
potassium you have the less heat you put
out less potassium vice-versa it's
inversely correlated so as co2 changes
what does that do to your potassium
concentrations what does it mean for
fire for you to see what does it mean
for fire intensity what does it mean for
air quality
what about ozone generation mentioned
our friend kudzu you know plants use
volatile organic carbons right so what
is co2 do in charge of processing those
that VOCs into ozone
what about contact dermatitis they have
little information on this one actually
comes from the face system with loblolly
pine that I showed you earlier turns out
when you give more co2 to a forest what
grows more than the forest you know what
else happens becomes more variant
more better able to give you contact
dermatitis about an orthotic
intensification oh gee you mean we're
actually spending public funds I'm
looking at controlling coca and and
poppy around the world yes we are so
what happens when co2 and temperature
change where we grow poppy and where we
go okay Oh what about food allergies see
if you changes quality does it change
all you missing a little bit of data for
peanuts showing that for some varieties
of light what about food safety as crazy
as it sounds warmer temperatures mean
that pathogens might increase I know
right so what's the government doing
well they've got the funds for the Food
Safety Inspection Service yes because
that makes the most sense ready
what about herbicide the system work I'm
running out of room here but this is
some work on Canada this what we did
this is under ambient co2 sprayed with
by the state got pretty good control
elevated co2 elevated co2 cause the
roots to grow more and so the same
amount of herbicide didn't kill the
plant the roots were able to regenerate
so we got zero control okay so yeah
alright I want to focus on just one
aspect of the oMG part I couldn't that's
nutrition there's strong evidence that
rejected increases in co2 will reduce
protein levels particularly protein
levels and many of the basic cereals
that feed the world particularly wheat
and rice so this is some work that I did
this before I left USDA this is with
polished rice looking at the percent
change in protein concentration free and
longer that is the change that's already
occurred in co2 it's about a five
percent change I think seven of the
eight lines showed a significant decline
it's all so ubiquitous this is some work
by Daniel tab back in 2008 but showing
the number of studies at that time for
barley was 20 this is the change in
protein concentration rice
soybeans so forth worth one point out
that for soybean we did not see a large
decline in protein in part because it's
a leguminous plant fixes over nitrogen
so peanut soybean do not show this is a
man approaching you're fine with more
co2 this is some meta-analysis by my
colleague Iraq legalized looking at
carbon he does have a little bit of
copper here but I don't think that's you
know related to 2-liter rice per se but
basically plants are very adaptable you
change the atmosphere that comes
carbon-rich - gonna add more carbon not
to be able to keep up there's a dilution
effect which going on there in terms of
the IMO it's not just crops this is some
work by Augustine at all it's a
seven-year average looking at pasture
grass and you can see the cow belching
over here and basically what it found
was that under ambient co2 Emmy and
temperature it means vo - elevated
temperature elevated co2 you haven't
support seven-year period you can see
the temperature per say did not have any
effect in terms of the protein
concentration but co2 did so there was
no interaction the carbon dioxide
reduced the protein as measured by
certain nitrogen as a result of that
change calves or cows put on weight it's
lowering it so it's not just in effect
in terms of plants that you need it's
also affect in terms of the meat that
you can see okay
hey it's just people food though right
well gee what if it happens to other
things other living things like bees
right these are
basically sugar Huggies
they love sugar they love wherever
nectar is and wherever they can get it
and they're so good at it that they do
the little wiggle dance right oh yeah
can you urge the left at the 7-eleven
you can find a sunflower
but they also get their protein from
pollen and they're not as good as being
able to select for protein sources in
nature they select by size and texture
not by the ability to know how much
protein is in that palm so to address
this issue of recent changes in co2
remember it's done up by 30% we want it
to be able to look at okay how is the
recent change in carbon dioxide affected
the protein concentration of pollen that
B is consumed tough one because bees
consume a lot of pollen from a lot of
different sources so we've chose
goldenrod solidago canadensis because
it's one of the last sources of flowers
that bees support unquote see before
they overwinter well how do we get to
that we have to go and look at the
historical evidence so where do we go
for that well we went to the Smithsonian
it's a great place if you've never been
they have your typical dinosaurs your
typical you know dying elephants the
Hope Diamond and then way in the back or
way in the bottom in the back right next
to the Ark of Covenant you'll find all
these you'll find all these different or
barium samples of goldenrod and these
are variants apples go back to the 1840s
cool let's sample those let's see what
we get so we looked at carbon hydrogen
nitrogen animal analysis because protein
of course will is degraded and pollen by
that will use nitrogen as a surrogate
for aging and we also wanted to look at
experimental evidence
historical evidence is cool but what's
the experimental evidence how can we do
that well Wayne Poly of USDA has this
really cool system with these little
Conestoga wagons at you see here and
what he's doing is he's adding co2 at
one end of the Conestoga wagon and being
that it's in Texas the sun is shining
foot since the co2 is being reduced
yeah and that's co2 its group to the
next one that gets moved to the next one
that gets booked to the next one and so
by the end of the Conestoga wagons the
co2 is pre-industrial so you can
actually we're very very fortunate to
have enough solid Eagle along those
transects we'll give you both the
historical analysis and an experimental
analysis and here's the data from the
sassoon Ian each dot is 20 specimens or
something I forgotten but basically
estimated protein goes down about 25% in
the recent last hundred years or so and
the carbon hydrogen ratio goes up and
from the experimental Conestoga wagon
experiment fewer samples bigger you know
variation but generally the same trends
that we saw both experimental and
historically so yeah it has more than
just people food and we're at the moment
a couple months ago we went back to the
Smithsonian we did another eight or nine
taxa doing the same kind of carbon
nitrogen we haven't analyzed those data
yet they want to see if this is just a
one-off thing or so one of the questions
then one of the hypothesis because with
this is okay if this is happening then
what does it mean for B health is it a
contributor to something like colony
collapse and the answer is we don't know
we know that B health can be important
as a means to deal with environmental
stressors but we don't have a direct
link as yet so we do a deeper dive this
is a variation of what I showed you for
level decline afraid of face system here
looking at 18 different lines these are
the 18 different lines of rice four
percent
pretty ubiquitous among all the
different lines and if you're familiar
with rice this is putting hybrids
hanukkah's and because this is the iron
the zinc composure little more variation
here but again general trend is for a
reduction we wanted to go a little bit
more we weren't able to do this for all
18 lines but we did it for 9 of the 18
and this is revital into the 1 b 2 b 5
and B 9 and again they're you know
significant effects cumulative for all
of these and some individuals as well
and then we got this alpha copper all
vitamin A which not yeah I me sorry
which one else whoa
okay why is it going down over here and
why is it going up over there what the
hell's going on right so we have a firm
possibility of a definite maybe which we
were referred to as a working hypothesis
for the moment and that is that it's
related to the carbon nitrogen issue but
if I have a compound that has a lot of
carbon in it and less nitrogen it may be
favored but if I have a compound that
has a lot of nitrogen in it it may be
disadvantaged and may go down so vitamin
b9 has as a ratio of molecular weight ed
to the vitamin about 22% of the
molecular weight of vitamin b9 is
hydrogen and it's the one that's most
adversely affected whereas after all has
no nitrogen and it was the one that was
not affected at all so I won't go
through all the variations of this we
wanted to look at it from the
perspective of rice is not consumed
equally among all the different
countries some countries consume more
rice than others and therefore any co2
induced effect on nutrition will not be
equally shared so a country like
Bangladesh for example which nine
seventy percent of their calories come
from rice on a daily basis may be more
impacted than other countries so that's
what that was about
we're trying to work on the ten poorest
countries now this is
food production as a function of
population average for the ten poorest
countries in the world this is
population and open circles this is
production in the closed circles and
then kilograms per person per year and
see it going down and then when you add
the elevated co2 effect on protein as a
result of this for the basic staples
within those countries to solve amazed
potatoes and so forth there's an
additional factor in terms of food
security not only in terms of production
but also in terms of nutritional quality
what else might be happening in terms of
micronutrients other things we simply
don't know so plant interact by multiple
means in human health from air quality
to medicine to nutrition
I would just add to that that I think
it's about more than just people I think
this is something to consider in the
context of plants are the basis of all
life can you affect how they function
you're going to affect all of biology in
ways that we don't necessarily
understand and to give you a sense of
this there's a paper I can't remember
the reference but it estimated all the
biomass plants and animals so this is
all the human biomass is about 0.06
gigatonnes for carbon all animals is
about two gigatonnes of carbon plants
are 450 gigatonnes of carbon or as we
like to say in the plant world plants
rule animals drool okay so understanding
this aspect I think is extremely
important in terms of understanding what
the impacts are going to be and this to
finish we acknowledge these interactions
in terms of human health I would just
caution that there is the ability to do
more that we need to find common ground
let's see that we need to collaborate
that we need to work closely that we
need to come up with new means and
methods to begin to address some of
these issues and that I hope that you'll
work with the proportion of the increase
in pollen the elevated sea of who you
think it to decrease plants versus these
reef production per unit rate if you
look at the ratio was mostly due the
plant size not so much food per plant so
we think it is I think it's bigger it's
more people yes anybody looked at what
so the herbivore biocontrol agents and
then what the there's been some work
quite a bit of work actually by
entomologist looking at how the change
in quality will affect feeding habits so
at Fair which was back in the 1980s with
that insects would basically eating more
of the leaf in order to gain the same
amount of protein
under high co2 condition
and so yeah I mean those that sort of
under control laboratory study in the
real world I don't know what the numbers
might be but I will point out that when
it comes to models which weren't a lot
of work information comes from the model
impact of s in terms of agriculture and
food security it's not very well
described not at all actually
some any other questions yes it's kind
of a segue to my question I'm wondering
if you're working with anybody trying to
put your results in some type of a
roughly physiologically based model it
seems like you have enough information
to make some predictions or at least
well-structured hypotheses that and then
try to intersect those with some of the
bigger no issues we're trying to focus
for the moment on nutrition per se and
what this means for differences in terms
of future co2 regarding nutritional
impacts on a regional basis and beach
Robert Beach is pretty financially
Policy Research Institute that was one
of the co-authors we put together a
paper that came out in Lancet planetary
health thank a couple months ago that
being said there's nowhere near where
we're done
and so we are I just spoke with Cynthia
Rosenzweig
Agnetha and we want to do more of this
work to try and get a better sense of
what sir two questions first one is
technical I'm working with apples in
many cases a tree is source limited so
do you think such scenario elevators you
to benefit the benefit fruit production
sure sure
one of the things that we've been
working on is trying to breed
trying to select for wheat and rice and
other annual cereals to respond to more
carbon dioxide I left this out as part
of the good aspect
no one has their cell phone else would
you do the following yeah if you type
carbon dioxide and marijuana
I tell me the first thing you get how to
use co2 take reseals in your marijuana
you co2 to get free shields in your
marijuana comes so if I yeah I mean it
hasn't been to my knowledge for apple
growers however you go online find out
that marijuana growers know when to
apply the co2 how much co2 to apply what
your THC content can be variety for
marijuana you should so all I can say is
I think we're missing an opportunity
here not that way but looking at it from
the point of view of food and food
security as a means to begin to select
for these lines that might be better
apples thing one of those one of the
commodities thank you second question
yes I'm you have worked at USDA for many
years yes just curious what prompted you
to these nasty if you want one all the
details Politico in my last name and
you'll get more than but basically the
work that I described to you for rice at
USDA before we submit paper we have to
get approval and if it's a sensitive
issue it has to be approved above the
normal approval basis there has to be
somebody in the national program
level that has to approve them so when
we submitted the price paper we got
approval we sent it to science science
said yeah they scented the science
advances science advances improved it
few months later we get a an email from
the editor saying you know this might be
a press release so we we asked the
different authors to do a press release
and then within 24 hours I got a message
from USDA saying oh the data don't
support your conclusions
what do you mean the papers in press
it's been peer-reviewed and it's coming
out and you now you think after you
approve it that the paper does no wait
what so we asked for details and they
wouldn't meet with me they wouldn't do
anything and then they did something
that I think crossed an ethical line
which is they started calling co-authors
at their institutions and saying don't
put out a press release for this and at
that point I felt I had to look for
sometimes in plants that the nitrogen
concentration or a high oxygen
concentration is some suggestion is
final and you might be linked to lower
levels of condolence or some do you
ceiling we get is reduction program you
do the compounds taking the tablet
receive I know and this is one of the
big mysteries that we have we have a
little bit of data so I agree that
working at policies out there that
Waseda n ratio may be something that
affects where these different compounds
are being impacted and what's going on
what's going down but honest to god
there's a lot that we don't know the
only thing I would say with some
certainty is it's kind of change and
what how it change is under and under
what degree it changes ramifications not
just for human health but I think for
many parts of the food chain
great I know our time is up let's thank
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu